all
[Music]
sha where are you
baby you know they say it's the last
free place in
America and it is you know for people
that live here year round people got
places they can stay you know and
they're safe you
know we do have Nam streets we do have
neighborhoods like a normal City but
we're not paying land rent we can never
pay land rent
here what do I need a city
for could just live out here for
free
if Palm Springs and Deadwood South
Dakota were to have an illegitimate
child it would be Slab
City and that's Deadwood South Dakota of
1876 not
[Music]
today
shria oh
shria where are you
baby
sha damn it dog where are
you my name is Robert Lane uh came down
here two and a half years ago to visit
my best friend
and he wanted to
trade his place for my truck after
thinking about it for a day um I decided
to stay so he took my truck and I got a
home I always start off with my hometown
news even though I haven't been there in
nearly 3
years it's nice to be able to know
what's going on in other parts of the
world and know that people are the same
everywhere they all have the same
worries and concerns that we
do color of our skin doesn't mean
[Music]
[__]
you [__] around with children or
threaten the children you're going to
see my dark side um I've even trained my
dogs to protect the children around
here last week somebody had every last
possession they owned stolen or
burned um it's what's known as slab
Justice he was he was a real [__] he
went to jail 2 weeks ago for threatening
somebody and within 24 hours of him
being in jail all of his stuff was
stolen and burned to the
ground nobody called the police when the
fire was immediately
set they waited till it was
unextinguishable before calling the fire
department that's how hated this person
was so there is there are morals out
here they're just
different a lot of people have put a lot
of taboo about it but it's just like any
other neighborhood any other City any of
that that you'd find here in the US as
far as I'm I
know where's that bag that sounds like
it's oh [__] it's the same thing to me
man somebody took my [__] travel bag
I'm going to beat the [__] out of
them where's my
bag there's a [__] black widow there
don't be putting your goddamn hand down
there grab your [__] no black widow's
right there have you seen my green duck
bag yeah it's right here
[Music]
bro you you just get the wrong
impression you
know I mean I if I looked at somebody
like this that looked like me I don't
think I would trust him but I'm the most
trustworthy person you'll ever find I
mean you give me $1,000 to hold for you
for 6 months when you come back you
might get $999 back you know I might I
spend a dollar on some bubble gum that I
can't
chew [__]
buried hey the wind sto
blowing
life is good out
[Music]
here
some hippies do shave not very many but
[Music]
so I own a place called The Slab City
internet cafe the only public place in
town for internet electricity and in the
morning's
[Music]
coffee the coffee situation it's
interesting he don't even like coffee I
can't stand the crap it's the nastiest
tasting stuff I've
ever
tried and I tried it twice just to make
sure he has never drank coffee he's
going to live longer than us
I can't even stand the smell of it the
smell turns my stomach but my customers
like coffee so I give them coffee in the
morning he taught me how to make it his
way D will you carry this one
out ho [__] shoing mall ah so great Java
loves us ah so
good my day usually starts pretty early
winter time I'll start coffee about 6:00
in the morning to get coffee out for the
customer by 700 I wouldn't know if I
make good coffee or bad but I've been
told I make the best cup in the
[Music]
county it gathers a lot of coffee in
your mouth before you even try to take a
sip I do coffee from 7 till 10: or 7
till 11: depending on how many people
are
[Music]
around them open 7 days a week I don't
have coffee all day long because it
could uh drink me
dry
[Music]
oh I wasn't
blocking you said I run strictly solar
but I have enough power coming off my
panels that I can provide
electricity um up until couple you know
maybe 2 hours before
Sundown CH
you I have no power no lights no nothing
this place you can take your cell phone
you can plug it into a power cord you
can charge it up you can do that with
your computer too and if you you got
people you want to keep in touch with
why you can get online which seems to be
pretty unique I think he's got six or
eight batteries over there and then a
th000 watts of of solar power so that
people could come in there and plug in
you know and then uh all he's asking is
for donations you know so that he can
pay for some of that stuff you know
Rob's one of my best
friends the cafe has always been
uh it's always been like a home for me
home away from home you know uh it's
probably one of my favorite places to
hang
out pretty [__]
awesome it's a community it's like a a
small neighborhood everybody out here is
pretty much like family not everybody
but most of
[Music]
us damn it's already 11:00
God this morning's gone
quick hey
Charlie come here boo come here
[Music]
booy
shria oh
[Music]
shria
shria damn that
[Music]
dog
shria come
on you know it took a little while to
get used to the heat but uh it
definitely beats
cold less than 300 people live here
during the summer um winter time there
could be as many as 2,000 people here um
but come June and the real heat they're
all gone you're talking just the just
the people who can tolerate extreme
Heats which is a very very hard thing to
do for a lot of people that comeing out
without the knowledge or understanding
of this desert because it does get very
very hot in the summer
yeah uh
125°
130° like we're talking you know 50 55°
c for people who can't
convert hey
when it gets up to
125° I hardly ever drink during the
summer because uh the alcohol dehydrates
you so I do all my drinking when it's
cool and get my get my belly uh ready
for the
summer
[Music]
yeah
I'm not going anywh ever no in your mind
oh in my mind oh no in my brain I'm here
waiting on a bus don't you remember okay
yeah I'm here waiting on a couple of
buses and the
president but that's never going to
happen that's okay I'm still sit around
waiting
[Music]
sh I randomly found my way to Slab City
I was on my way to my friend's court
case in LA and we ran into a friend that
mentioned Slab City so we made the way
here we were in a BMW and that car blew
up we traded it for a van that blew up
and we finally made our way here I was
traveling through when people were
talking about this free place to live in
the winter and we came out here to check
it out and we got I fell in love with
the place I was like a snowbird I would
come down every winter over to Arizona
while I was camped there two ladies came
up and said George you ever been to Slab
City no I've heard of it you know but
I've never been there oh God you got to
go there you'd fit right in You' fit
right in to Slab City Life Snowbird is a
type of person who runs away from the
cold kind of like I did but they only
come down for the winter and then as
soon as the weather starts to warm up
they'll go back North to where they came
from
I decided to change my life
around be wild
and do the things they told me I
couldn't do when I was teenager and all
that other stuff rebell against society
and everything got myself in legal
troubles that sent me to prison for 7
years and in the last year I've just
gotten out of
prison there's
no hostility I don't think there's a
single person in here that hates another
person at all I mean it's been
amazing it's been a long time since I
felt this accepted in a random
environment now I'm starting
over my life as a single elderly lady
paid my debt to this society and got out
and came down here I hadn't intended on
staying uh permanently
um there's there's a lot of Quiet
Moments which is nice I spent a lot of
time in a big city I enjoy the big city
but I also like the peace and quiet of
the
[Music]
country
I don't know just coming here though has
really changed
me in multiple ways mentally physically
before I got here I was honestly just
hurting other people and myself because
of what I was and now I've came to a
realization of who I am and what I'm
worth and I have Slab City and the
people here to thank for that he come
here
[Music]
now
yeah we got enough for now there are no
Public Utilities out here so if you need
water you have to obtain it for yourself
you don't pay rent but you still pay you
got to pay for water you got to pay for
your food you got to pay for your
clothing and laundry the upkeep on your
dog the upkeep on your place you got to
pay for that you got to find a way to do
it out here the best you can uh one tank
is between 270 and 300 gallons of water
that usually lasts 3 to 4
weeks one of the great things about my
place is I'm the only one out here
that's got a a shower that's got a hot
water tank on it and everybody stops by
and I got to help them you it's not
really a public shower you know you do
got to come over and ask ask permission
but George is a nice enough guy that
most people he'll say yes to people come
by and I charge them $3 for a shower
because I got to burn my propane and
then the water too you know I got to run
in and haul my own water so three bucks
is pretty cheap you have to be very
conservative with your water out here if
you take a shower you take a trickle
shower you know you wet yourself down
turn the water off soap yourself up turn
the water back on rinse yourself off you
flip a light switch and it turns the
pump
on and you take a
shower you can do a shower in less than
five
gallons um that just means you've got
shower water for another day don't use
it during my TV
[Music]
time it's pretty
cool
oh you look so much better I'll bet you
smell better too I feel pretty can you
me my oh so
pretty yeah well you don't look any
better I give him his showers for free
that's that's how good of a friend it is
like it cost $3 to be my friend
yeah
ah a good day for me is a slight breeze
outside with nice Sunshine so I can go
outside and do my normal activities
I live out here in Slot City because
it's awesome I have three older brothers
and one
sister four
[Music]
dogs I work out here every Saturday
picking up garbage off the side of road
there's no more jobs out here to do
except being a gas station worker or uh
Food Market
[Music]
worker during the week I go over to
school and basically do nothing except
school
stuff then I just go home and do my
homework well supposedly do my homework
and that's about
it
I am still hoping to be able to go to
the Moon one
day I'm serious I I've been wanting I've
been wanting to go to the moon since
Neil Armstrong touch down in the moon in
Te
69 I may not be able to travel to
another star but in 5 10 years I could
very well stand on the moon and I would
love that I want to be like an soldier
in the US Army or Air Force somewhere
around there when I grow up because I
want to just hear gun battles and see
what it's really like instead of video
games and
movies
on the other side of the fence off of
Canal Road here in Slab City we have
three military bases we've got the
Marines the Air Force and the naval and
every once a while you get the airplanes
going over you get the bombs going off
you get firing and test sites is what it
is it makes it quite loud if you're not
used to it but you get used to it when
you're out here long
enough once in a while you'll see a
cloud of Smoke Rise up off the top of
the mountain and then like 10 seconds
later you'll hear this boom and the The
Cloud of smoke already be there you're
just hearing it afterwards it's a like
delayed I like seeing the helicopters
fly over our heads what they mainly do
in the morning is go really really low
and really really
loud they're not supposed to wave at us
uh about a month ago there was three of
them that flew they were flying real low
over here and I stood out here with a
beer waving at them and somebody hung
out the door and wav back I don't know
if they got in trouble for it or not but
that was the first time in 2 and 1/2
years anybody had never waved back so
yeah it made me feel pretty good they
saw
me
[Music]
you know how you sit around notes in
like classes and [__] and the teacher
tries to catch you and it doesn't work
well anyway we're passing around notes
and Miss Reed comes around listen Mr
Fields what are you doing passing around
notes while I'm trying to teach a class
I'm like well I'm bored boring as she
and she was like and she was like well
you can leave this classroom right now
and get suspended or you can stay in
this classroom and go to detention I'm
like Miss Reed you're my favorite
teacher I love science but if you give
me detention I'm not going I'd say I'm
kind of a greeter but I'm kind of family
too a bunch of the kids that like to
talk to me and hang around with me I'm
saying kids like half my age 20 year
olds they they adopt me as Mom and I was
thinking to myself why do I have the
tension I haven't done anything wrong so
you know what I did I stopped doing all
my work okay I didn't do [__] [__] I
went into the class and I put my head
down they won't say it out loud or
anything else but there's a couple of
them that look at me like moms so I kind
of fit into that role I've had five kids
you know my youngest is 21 my oldest is
30 I for grandkids right now haven't
seen any of them so it finally came to
the point where I met the principal so
I'm sitting here like this sleeping on
my desk and this [__] comes in
takes that big ass [__] textbook off
the table SL the table [__] he didn't
hit the table he hit me want you to have
IDE I jumped up out that chair and
[__] knocked him one right in his
[__] mouth well Zach it's my brother
personally that dude is funny he is I
like waking up and Jack is right there
knowing that I got a brother that's with
me right now that's why you don't ever
see them three
[__] my brother were killed by the
law enforcement and my cousin was killed
because of
Gams I missed him so
much I miss him I was flipping the [__]
out I'm not allowed on any public school
grounds in
California
ever
ever Z is my guy he's cool man he helped
me out when I first came here and he was
like you I like you and I'm like like
you too bro we been cool ever
since metal changing temperatures faster
than the
water did you take my cigarette
yep man I can't have nothing around here
no
go you know Casey and to me my older
brother taught them that it was cool to
run up to me as fast and hard as they
could power slide and punch me in the
balls I can't have any more kids besides
the one I have and I don't feel anything
if you punch me in the testicles so good
luck you don't feel pain in your
testicles I don't feel pain in this foot
cuz I've been kicked in it so many times
cuz everybody keep thinking that's my
weak spot no buddy it's actually my
strong
spot all through my life people that
thought just because I walk like this
that that foot is my weakness at one
time it used to be but so many people
have tried to kick me in there actually
have kicked me in there that I felt pain
when it first started but I'm just so
used to getting kicked there doesn't
mind it mind it no more and I'm going to
do to you what I would do to anybody
else that throws a kick at me I'm going
to grab your fo you think you're
Invincible bro I'm not Invincible but
I'm going to grab that fo what you're
think so let's go out there and test the
theory or it can get dropped right now
you want to go test that theory
I won't put you to sleep but you will
TR I love music actually I am a beat
Creator have been making beats since I
was young started getting good everybody
recognized was like you're doing good
man you should keep going okay kept
going you can hear one of my
instrumentals it has a piano solo
ha the Beat
Drops
[Music]
Dam tap
tap
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
no not
[Music]
again Middle School I got tired of
getting bullied so I'm like okay I'm
crippled like okay so I'm going to get
my fighting yours better join wrestling
learn how to wrestle win some you lose
some but you live to fight another
day never give up
[Music]
[__] that my friend is a professional
wrestling
match
I smile a lot because I try to hide all
the pain that's inside of me that's all
I do every
day we do have a moral code AS warped as
it may seem at times there is a moral
code out
here it may be a little anarchical out
here everybody lives by their own rules
as long as it doesn't interfere with me
or affect my life negatively adults can
do as they
please as skewed as it may seem to the
rest of the world um we have a very
strong moral
fiber your neighbor waking you up at
3:00 in the morning when you're sound
asleep then go live in a residential
Community where there's a [__]
bedtime and C so I don't give a [__] for
twe weers anymore than I give a [__] for
alcoholics I Bann that [__] my conding
the bad the bad behavior of people but
I'm saying you can't categorize someone
by the substance they
do you know what yes I can because if
they know they have a problem they have
the power to stop it I I respect Rob
he's he's trying to do well over there
he started getting tired of the tweaker
so he started running them out you know
and
and everybody liked liked him for that
you know they stay up all night yelling
and screaming and everything and he was
getting tired of
it we have a big problem with meth
addicts out here Americans call them
Tweakers because they like to tweak with
things uh stealing things from other
people you know they're they're very
desperate drug
addicts and the police uh can't do much
about that and they're not much worried
about it either it's very hard to get
the police to uh respond out
here you can't make rules in the place
where there's no rules you even have a
so you got the [__] right to wake me
up at 3 and morning [__] you you even
have a sign in front of the internet
cafe we remember freedom freedom is not
the right to [__] your neighbors a lot
of people didn't like what they saw here
personally and refuse to see the whole
picture and they go away thinking that
Slab City is nothing but a bunch of drug
addicts and it's not that it's an artist
Community there are unfortunately a lot
of alcoholics and drug users here um
that's the type of place it is when you
don't have to pay
rent you're keeping us all up over here
because you got all these [__]
Tweakers over here and y'all are always
up all [__] night well guess what
you're going to [__] leave it if you
don't like it shit's going to start
[Music]
happening come on
Rob I'll be there in a
minute there may sometimes be a lot of
yelling and screaming but you know what
it's better to yell and scream and get
it out than to hold it in let it build
up and let it come to the point where
you harm
somebody
[Music]
and I understand what you're saying Rob
and I apologize I I I get it and I agree
but how can you take someone's side and
let them come in when it's not his
[__] situation and he's done more
damage to the slabs than anybody [__]
here Zach has had just like a lot of the
people here has had a very [__] up
life I have a chance given time to show
Zach that there are better
ways he could have walked up behind that
guy and put him in the [__] grave he
didn't the Zach that I met 2 and 1/2
years ago would have just [__] taken
a club and beat the guy over the hand
dude I'll beat the [__] out of you with
both of these coffee Thermoses and then
pour them on you all
right I can't say nothing bad about him
all the people be like oh he's this he's
that you know I've been with Zach ever
since I've been here and I haven't seen
him do nothing wrong unless it's for a
reason you have to respect people out
here and we're not going to respect you
at
all hey look at these
douchebags hey look there a couple of f
look at the C worms this is an alpha
Community every everybody up here is an
alpha um and of course when two Alphas
come together they're eventually going
to butt heads if they don't have their
space but we do live we do for the most
part live in harmony Rob doesn't like
violence at the cafe we don't induce
violence at the cafe we try to stop it
as much as we can
Cafe um the only thing I allow is pot
anything harder and they get tossed out
I don't even allow alcohol anymore if
they want to go get drunk they can go
somewhere [__]
[Music]
else
hey I try not to make be negative as
much as I can when negativity happens
when there's fights and stuff like that
I try to forget those I remember them
but I try not to Harbor on them and I
try to look at the chirping of the birds
you know the uh beauty of the desert I
try to remember something beautiful in
that situation and that's what I try to
live my life
[Music]
by sorry
Rob
I accept your apology I know that you
none none of what you did was
[Music]
intention
well Rob I got to tell you he he's one
of the wisest men I've met actually the
way he brings himself and the way he
like if somebody gets an argument the
way he defuses it and the way he words
things and he loves to conversate with
people he loves learning about people
and he just loves people robs great
[Music]
person
hey Steve yeah I'm just peeking in to
see if sha is in here yes came in she
shrika did come in
yes shria are you in here
baby no she not in
here
tra
a lot of us got our dogs and we get
attached to them the cafe has got their
own dogs they were puppies that were
born together of the same litter if we
didn't have all the dogs then it would
be a lot of problems around here cuz
whenever I get angry all I do is pick up
my puppy and look at her face and all my
anger leaves ch
good you teach it gentle yes you teach
it gentle KO we protect children we
protect animals we treat our animals
better than we treat ourselves me and my
dog we usually spend all day here with
nobody coming around I enjoy the
Solitude of just being alone and being
able to
relax yeah I love it out here I just
love
it
H if I had one
wish I wish I could find me a a nice
woman uh I even posted it online on
Facebook you know I'm looking for a nice
woman to stay with me do the cooking
cleaning do my
laundry and everybody said you want a
maid you don't want a [__]
wife tomorrow's my birthday I want to be
65 years old and I figur well it would
be nice to settle down a little bit and
it'd be nice to have a woman to share
that with you
know and now I'm getting all sentiment
and all that [__] you
know
[Music]
yeah
shria
[Applause]
ra you get to know the animals you get
to know them by name you know they're
run up they'll talk to you they'll say
hi to you in the mornings and they go on
to their journey of the day there you
are baby hi come here come on you had me
worried Bab baby come on up yeah oh yes
hi
Gator yes High
Gator you had me worried baby well then
I got to avoid the police until April
30th is it traffic tickets it's traffic
court it's not a ticket bro it's a
[__] evading arrest and I also
destroy you evading arrest I destroyed a
cop car with an F350
hey [__]
off you're going to come play right next
to me while I'm drinking coffee piss off
go
go go [__] and that's how I got
caught up and that's why I'm going
through all this stupid [__] now
today is my brother Zach's birthday and
he is turning 19 and we're going to
celebrate it by doing everything under
the son that cannot get us in
trouble while still having fun at the
same time I at least have to not go to
jail until after my
birthday I will eventually one day be
leaving um there'll come a day where I
won't be able to go up on the roof
anymore move the panels
[Music]
around hey Zach you want to come
here yeah come here I need your fix this
a little bit CU now that we've got this
back we can't have the cord hang now so
I need
to
and when that day comes that that will
definitely be the day that I leave um
who knows it it may be sooner but right
now this is
[Music]
home
and we are going to get so hammered
tonight I don't know what we're doing
but we're going to have fun tonight we
are the range is a very special place I
advise
everybody to come to the range at Slab
City
[Music]
please Saturdays like tonight is one of
the biggest nights of the week because
we all gather up on the stage that was
set up by Builder bill and it's called
AR range that's when the alcohol blows
through and I do have my good times on
Saturday night Sundays are my day off I
don't do nothing somebody comes over
want something done I'll tell them I'll
do it on Monday because I I've usually
got a hangover it's fantastic I just go
out there and dance dance my heart out
and I'm better when I come back on
Sunday a whole better person
[Music]
again
yeah we work hard and we play hard out
here too different tones different
pitches different instruments I've seen
all the way from a cello to a flute to
harmonica playing the blues up there on
that range it is range of
[Music]
music
down down
on in
a so good
I may go down to listen to listen to a
new musician for half an hour to an hour
but that's pretty much it this place
keeps me pretty busy and by the time
that's going I'm pretty tired just want
to sit back and
[Music]
relax
[Applause]
oh
I miss human as everybody else I make my
stupid
mistakes but I do tend to be
self-reflective think about you know
jeez what what I just do what I want to
really
[Music]
do
don't stop learning don't stop
growing work harder each day to be a
better person than you were yesterday
and never rest on your
[Music]
laurels for your own personal growth you
need to constantly
learn that's the mistake too many people
make is resting on their accomplishments
you got to keep doing something
[Music]
new my mother worked for the same
employer for 32 years my sister is
months away from putting in her 30th
year with a single
employer couldn't do
it maybe if I was an astronaut for NASA
yes I plan on going to the Moon before I
die
chill
around places
everywhere you could find
any they were
free they were
Happ they were
free they
[Music]
they keep kicking me off of the private
Network and it's really pissing me off
so before you leave we definitely have
to take care of the internet and me
getting on and off
without complications
yeah
[Music]